[Music]
That's right.
Still
Hello, welcome. I can really hear myself
there. Um, hi everybody. Welcome. My
name is Valerie. My pronouns are she,
her, and we're glad everyone's here
tonight. We have a couple of
announcements. Um, first up, our state
of the table, which is kind of just like
a meeting covering um leadership
transitions, budgets, stuff that's going
on in the next six months. That's going
to be on September 21st. It'll be at 400
pm, which and it'll finish up right
before service at 5. So, we hope
everyone can make that. Also, save the
date. October 11th, we're gonna have a
booth at North Pride, North Texas Pride
in Plano. And we're looking for
volunteers to help man the booth between
about 12 and 5:00 p.m. If you're
interested, there'll be a QR code coming
up. You can scan the QR code and get
more information.
Finally, if you're feeling a little
anxious about being in the uh church
setting or maybe you're part of the
disability community or just feeling a
little extra fidgety today, um we have
an accessibility bucket. It's right off
here to my left. Um we've got some um
noise cancelling headphones there,
fidgets, coloring sheets. Anything you
want to help yourself to, that's fine.
We just ask that you return it after
service when you're done.
These candles on either side of me are a
sign of the presence of Christ.
Fully divine and fully human.
Now we exit the kingdom of noise, hurry,
and productivity.
Now we enter the kingdom of silence,
stillness, and simplicity.
sacred space,
a place for prayer, worship, and
adoration.
A place to behold Christ, revelation of
God, heartbeat of creation.
Allow the unforced rhythms of grace to
find you and to mend your heart. May we
all come home.
Thank you. If you guys would stand with
us, we're going to get started with our
music tonight. And I hope that it
encourages you, that it lifts you up,
and that you remember that you are not
alone. Together in this space, we are a
community who wants to anchor ourselves
into the joy and uh the redemption of
the gospel and of Jesus. So, I hope that
his spirit is close tonight as you
worship.
I raise a hallelujah
[Music]
in the presence of my enemies.
I raise a hallelujah
louder than the unbelief.
[Music]
I'll raise a hallelujah.
My weapon is a melody.
[Music]
I raise a hallelujah.
Heaven comes to fight for me.
And I'm going to sing
in the middle of the storm.
Louder and louder, you're going to hear
my praises roar.
Up from the ashes,
hope will arise.
Death is defeated.
The king is alive.
[Music]
I raise a hallelujah
with everything inside of me.
[Music]
I raise a hallelu
and I will watch the darkness flee.
Hooray.
I raise a hallelujah
in the middle of the mystery.
[Music]
I raise a hallelujah.
Fear you lost your hold on me.
I'm going to sing
in the middle of this storm.
Louder and louder. You're going to hear
my praises roar.
Love from the ashes.
Hope will arise.
Death is defeated.
The king is alive.
Oh,
[Music]
>> sing a little louder.
>> Sing a little louder.
>> We're going to sing a little louder.
>> Going to sing a little louder.
Sing a little louder.
>> We're going to sing a little louder.
>> Sing a little louder.
>> Sing a little louder
>> in the presence of my enemies.
>> Sing a little louder.
>> Louder than the unbelie.
>> My weapon is a melody. We're going to
sing a little louder.
>> Heaven comes to fight for me.
>> Sing a little louder.
>> In the presence of my enemy.
>> Louder than the
>> We're going to sing a little louder.
>> Melody,
>> we're going to sing a little louder.
comes to fight for me.
>> Sing a little louder.
I'm going to sing
in the middle of the storm.
Louder and louder. You're going to hear
my praises roar
up from the ashes.
Hope will arise.
Death is defeated.
The king is alive. Oh, I'm going to sing
in the middle of the storm.
Louder and louder. You're going to hear
my praises roar
out from the ashes.
Hope will arise.
Death is defeated.
The king is alive.
Oh.
[Music]
All right, kiddos. You guys are
dismissed.
Y'all can follow Justice over there, and
your teachers will meet you by the door.
Thank you again, Risa and Maggie, and I
think August is back in kids ministry
and other teachers. So grateful for
y'all.
And we are going to transition into the
prayers of the people. So, if this is
your first time here, um this is a
tradition passed down through Christian
history that we participate in each week
mostly with the hope that we are
bringing into this space the things that
we carry with us, whether it's a person
that's on your heart or a situation. Um
we want to lift those up together before
God and before each other and hold space
for that honestly as a community. So,
you can follow along on the screen. um
the parts in red we'll read out loud
together and then we'll leave space in
the middle to share um anything that's
on your heart tonight and then we'll
close out the prayer again at the end.
Jesus for this city of Saxi, Texas and
for every city and community and all who
live in them. We pray to you for the
good earth you have given us and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it. We
pray to you for the old and the sick,
for the widow and orphan, for the
injured and suffering. We pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed, the
unemployed and destitute, for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them. We pray to you for the
vulnerable, the marginalized, and those
unjustly targeted for their gender,
sexuality, race, or other perceived
difference. We pray to you for those
experiencing loss, loneliness, and
disconnection. And for those struggling
with mental and emotional health, we
pray to you, Lord. We know that you love
us and that you hear us. So we lift
these names and situations up to you,
[Music]
for Minneapolis,
for Johnny Owen,
for Angelina.
[Music]
And God, we also hold in our hearts
tonight those who were impacted by the
Minneapolis school shooting.
[Music]
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those we have
kept in our hearts. We pray to you that
they may have life and light, healing
and hope, peace, and a deep sense of
your presence. Amen.
Sing. We have suffered.
We have suffered all kinds of grief.
Tasted the bitter cup of defeat.
Out of the bitter comes something sweet.
Our faith more precious than gold.
>> We have been tested by so many fires,
burned in the heat of what our hope
requires.
[Music]
>> Find us here singing in a foolish choir.
Our faith more preious than gold.
Though we don't see you, we love you.
When we don't feel you, we still see.
>> We've got a reason to trust you.
Jesus in everything.
[Music]
>> There is a secret we can only know.
Walking through places we don't want to
know.
Cuz in the dark we learn the song of
hope. Our faith more preious than gold.
[Music]
Our faith more preious than gold.
Though we don't see you, we love you.
When we don't feel you, we still sing.
We've got a reason to trust you.
Jesus in everything.
Tears on the altar
from all we've lost.
Following you no matter what it costs.
Maybe a whisper,
maybe a roar. This is the sound of those
who love you, Lord. This is This is the
sound of those who love you.
>> Sing tears on the altar.
>> Tears on the altar
from all we've lost.
Following you, no matter what it cost
us. Maybe a whisper,
maybe a roar. This is the sound of those
who love you, Lord. This is the sound of
those who love you, Lord.
Though we don't see you, we love you.
When we don't feel you, we still sing.
We've got a reason to trust you.
Jesus in everything.
Though we don't
though we don't see you, we love you.
When we don't feel you, we still sing.
We've got a reason to trust you.
Jesus in everything.
Jesus.
[Music]
Jesus in everything.
Jesus.
Tears on the altar
from all we've lost.
Following you. No matter what it costs.
Maybe a whisper,
maybe a roar. This is the sound of those
who love you, Lord. This is the sound of
those who love you. This is This is the
sound of those who love you, Lord.
[Music]
I wanted to share with you guys real
quick. Um, this week I was texting with
actually one of my daughter's coaches
and she was recently in this um, tragic
car accident and ended up being in ICU
for a while and uh, she's a volleyball
coach. That's her livelihood. and now
she's having to relearn how to walk um
how to like bear weight on her legs. And
uh so I've just been like trying to
check in on her every week or so. And I
reached out this week and said like, you
know, how's it going? And um she kind of
shared, you know, like, well, hey, I can
lift myself on and off the toilet by
myself now. And I was like, woo,
victories. You know, when you're
celebrating something like that, you're
like, man, this is this is a loss, you
know.
um she has little boys. She was supposed
to get married this month. I don't know
what they're doing with the wedding
ceremony and everything, but um
her the end of her text stopped me
because um I'm like reaching out to
encourage her. What she ended up saying
is, "Hey, thanks for reaching out, but
God's got me and he's not finished me
with me yet." And it just like took me
back, you know, because it's easy for us
to say that when little things go wrong,
but when something major really stops
you dead in your tracks and kind of
rewrite writes the story of your life
for a little while, those words come at
a cost sometimes. You know, it means
something different when you're having
to relearn how to walk and you're like,
you know what? But God's not done yet.
There's more to this story. And um it
just encouraged me. It reminded me why
our faith can be so valuable. Um, and
scriptures like though the sorrow may
last for a night, joy comes in the
morning, started to go through my head.
Or scriptures like he who began a good
work in you will be faithful and just to
complete it.
and scriptures like trust in the Lord
with all your heart and he will direct
your path.
Those kinds of verses mean something
different when you're really having to
trust when when everything's really on
the line and and we have to believe God,
you're going to do something good with
this.
And the song that we're about to sing is
called Canvas and Clay. And it's just
about that message right there.
believing that there is a good God who
is writing a good story in your life who
is partnering with us and believing that
there is something worth holding on to
here. There is hope. There will be joy.
Even if right now we're in the middle of
sorrow and doubt and confusion,
brokenness, divorce, addiction,
whatever your sorrow is right now, I
believe that God's message to us is joy
will come in the morning.
So let's hold on to that tonight as we
gather tonight. As we sing, I hope that
God lifts up that hope and that joy
inside of you.
[Music]
In my mother's womb,
you formed me with your hands. Known in
love by you
before I took a breath. When I doubt it,
Lord, remind me. I'm wonderully made.
You're an artist and a part. I'm the
canvas and the clay.
>> You make all things
work together
for my future
and for my good. You make all things
work together
for your glory
and for your name.
[Music]
There's a healing light
just beyond the clouds. Though I've
walked through fire,
I see clear now and nothing has been
wasted.
No failure or mistake. You're an artist
and departed.
and the canvas in the grave.
You make all things
work together
for my future
and for my good. You make all things
work together
for your glory
and for your name.
[Music]
For your name.
And when I doubt it, Lord, remind me I'm
wonderfully made. You're an artist and a
part of the canvas and the clay. And I
know nothing has been wasted. No failure
or mistake. You're an artist and a
partner. I'm the canvas and the clay. N
I doubt it. Lord, remind me I'm
wonderfully made. You're an artist and a
partner. I'm the chev.
I know nothing has been wasted. No
failure or mistake. You're in standard.
I'm the chemist in the clay.
Hey,
[Music]
you're not finished with me.
You're not finished with me. Yeah.
You're not finished with me.
You're not finished with me yet. You're
not finished with me. No. You're not
finished with me yet.
[Music]
Lord, you're my
You make all things
work together
for my future
and for my good. You make all things
work together
>> for your glory.
and for your name. Make all things
work together
for my future
and for my good. You make all things
work together
for your glory.
and for your name.
[Music]
[Laughter]
Jesus, would we anchor ourselves and our
lives into that truth tonight?
And if we don't believe it, God, would
you help us with our unbelief?
Would you come and make it real?
God, would we begin to see the different
strands of your love and your goodness,
your faithfulness, your redemption
weaving into our lives.
[Music]
God, would you bring people around us
who would remind us that you are the
author and the perfector of our faith
and you do not desert the work of your
hand.
God, would you stitch it into the fabric
of our heart?
We love you and we want to trust you.
So God come
rest on us.
Show us your love God in Jesus name.
Amen.
Thank you guys so much for worshiping
with us. And um as you sit down, would
you just turn to the person next to you
and say, "The peace of Christ be with
you.
Well, grace and peace. Super good to be
with you all. My name is Brett and I'm
the pastor here. My pronouns are he,
him, and yeah, it's a joy joy to be with
you in this space and to to worship with
you. Thanks uh worship team. That was
really yeah a lovely set. There's
something something about music. It's
powerful man. The way it works works on
us and uh I think God uses it in
powerful ways. So really grateful for
that team. Uh and also want to uh
welcome those join us online. You're not
forgotten. Love y'all lots. Uh glad you
could be with us too. And um let's see.
Okay. So we are in uh week two in our
series or sorry no actually this is week
three um titled cultivating calm staying
centered in difficult times and uh you
know we live we live in a time of uh of
pretty high stress. Uh I I think I
there's lots of theories on why this
isn't you know what's what's going on. I
think some of it is just as we get kind
of distanced from the natural world and
the rhythms of things. I mean, there was
a time, you know, when it used to be
like when the sun went down, everything
was dark except for like your candle and
your little fire, you know what I mean?
And it was just like, have you ever been
camping? Um, and you know, like by 9:00
it's sort of like, well, I guess time to
go to bed, you know? There's nothing
else. I don't know what else you like
sleep great. You know, like there is
something about we're kind of distanced
from some of those rhythms. And then
just add to that all of the just the I
don't know the pace of change with
technology is absolutely like I mean
it's it's stunning. Uh and people have a
lot of anxiety around you know some of
that. Um and uh add to that just the
continued which we feel very acutely
here at the table the kind of continued
persecution and scapegoating of the
LGBTQ community in the in this country.
Uh and that's super difficult for uh so
many in in our community and of course
beyond. Uh and then you've got, you
know, wars. You got the war in Ukraine
and uh the then the mistreatment of the
Palestinians by the more conservative
wings of the Israeli state and uh
economic fears around you know tariffs
and the rise of AI like where's all that
going you know and then just add it all
to like that's kind of the big picture
very meta very you know stuff and then
you've got like you know just the
everyday crap like just you know like
money's running out you know or job
concerns or relationship struggles and
and you kind of start compounding all
that and we can very quickly just lose
um our sense of like calm and center and
you know a sense of like uh it's going
to be okay and that that deep uh peace
that we all long for. So that's kind of
what the series is about is like how do
we recover some of that? How do we kind
of live into and um gain uh a way to
live with that? So the title of my
message uh today is the battlefield of
the mind and our scripture is 2
Corinthians chapter 10:es 3-5.
It reads, "For though we live in the
world, we do not wage war as the world
does. The weapons we fight with are not
the weapons of the world. On the
contrary, they have divine power to
demolish strongholds. And we demolish
arguments and every pretension that sets
itself up against the knowledge of God.
And we take captive every thought to
make it obedient to Christ."
So the way I want to kind of set this
this message up is just by naming uh
first and foremost that there is a
really I think a good and holy and
beautiful work that the table here our
community that we've been kind of called
to. You know I think in a way God has
like a you know a thumbrint on every
church. They just have certain things
they emphasize certain people God brings
their way and uh and also certain
weaknesses and such you know which we're
not immune from either. But there's also
certain strengths, you know, in every
community. And I think part of the the
call of Christ has been um kind of a
call to bear witness to people's pain.
And it's really I mean, honestly, it's
the rare person who comes through our
doors.
And uh by the way, if this is your
first, second, or third time, you know,
we're really glad that you're here. And
we know that takes a ton of courage. And
uh it is it's the rare person who sort
of walks through our doors and really
has you know nothing but good things to
say about family history
uh relationship to the broader society
and church history. That is like the it
is a vanishingly rare person. I mean to
the point where if I meet someone and
they're kind of like no no all good. I'm
like, my jaw hits the floor. Like,
really? And you're at the you you're
here, you know? It's just like it's
shocking. Um, and so so much of what
we're doing right there is is kind of
bearing witness to that very real uh
pain, right? Holding space for them, as
the saying goes, uh, which kind of gets
poked fun at that that saying, but I
think it's kind of beautiful. It's this
idea of a a kind of non-reactionary
listening, right? Without kind of
getting pulled into like what what
happened to you? Well, I'm furious. and
now you're like feeding back their
nervous system. You know what I mean?
People need you to like hold some space,
kind of be that steadying presence that
can listen and absorb and take in, you
know, the difficult stories um that
folks go through. And so that's a really
beautiful gift to give one another and
and I pray that you know as we kind of
continue on this journey that we can
continue to be that kind of place for
folks because there I think there really
is just a there is a season in our life
uh often it can even extend for years
you know where that is like so the thing
we need you know this is the role of
therapy often in people's lives like
finally I have a safe space where I can
just like blah, you know, I mean, all
the secrets and the shame and the anger
and the, you know, whatever. Just I need
someone to hold some space and to be a a
listening empathetic ear. Um, and
that is that's good and beautiful and
holy work. And nothing really the rest
of this message isn't about like
minimizing that or saying like that's
not true or um what I do want to do
though is kind of build on that though
and say um that is a I would say very
essential kind of step in the process
but it is in fact a kind of journey
right in other words the the person
who's say um in their small church small
group or in therapy or meeting with
friends and for 30 years they're
rehashing, you know what I mean?
Something that happened to them way
back. Like you can see where there's
there can be kind of some um a kind of
stuckness,
you know what I mean? Um and it's that
stuckness that I kind of want to to
address. Um because yeah, I think while
giving voice to our pain, you know,
speaking with vulnerable honesty um
about where we've been is so beautiful
and essential um it's often just that
alone isn't enough to actually get to
where uh Christ I think is inviting us
to go to kind of grow and mature into
all that um that we could be. So um in
many ways then this message won't be for
everyone. you know, if you're kind of
here and this is like still very raw for
you and you're just not you are in that
season of just like I need a place to
share, you know, that's beautiful.
You're in that season and you can, I
don't know, just chill and maybe take
some notes for something. Maybe this
will be applicable later down the road.
Um others of you, you've totally, you
know, you've been at the table for five,
six years, had people bear witness to
the pain, and but you're sensing that
kind of stuckness in your own life, then
this might be um a little more
applicable to you. So um so, so what do
I mean by this? Well, we'll kind of come
at it sideways. Go back to 2 Corinthians
10. Start with verse three again. For
though we live in the world, we do not
wage war as the world does. It's an
interesting little phrase, isn't it? We
don't wage war as the world.
Uh what is what's that getting at? I
think if you if you kind of reflect on
that, I mean, of course, you could take
it super literally like we don't use
bombs, you know, or something. But if
you if you kind of go back even before,
you know, a bomb is ever dropped or a
shot is ever fired or, you know, what's
what's going on in in us as humans when
we wage war as the world does. I think
it's kind of this process of uh
of naming hey there there is an enemy
and that enemy is over there
and they must be there's different
versions at this point attacked
eliminated
uh at best kind of neutralized and
silenced marginalized you
And I I I think you can see where this
becomes a kind of habit of mind because
of course there are certain times in
season. This is where this message is a
little tricky because there is nuance
here where sometimes there really is an
enemy. You know what I mean? Like
sometimes there actually is like
especially I'm thinking of like an
abusive relationship or something. Not
maybe you have to use like they're my
enemy but you mean this is like a
dangerous person or it's not as simple
as um just kind of saying like oh no no
it's the problem's not them or you know
there's a sometimes there is an enemy.
Uh but you can see where that becomes a
kind of seductive
story
all the time. You know what I mean?
Almost like a way of life where like I'm
feeling some things. I got some like
emotional like I'm all upset, you know?
And
someone is to blame, you know? You can
see where as this we zoom out and this
you take this to like country you you
know states and countries and empire
level and it's like oh my gosh you know
it's this perpetual um kind of story.
You can see where it becomes a very
socially, politically persuasive,
convenient and sticky like storyline,
right? Again, not just to use on those
occasions when it's like true, but all
the time it becomes a kind of perpetual
story to rally the troops.
And so the politician or the leader or
even the pastor, whole church is built
on this, isn't there? There is an enemy
out there. Out those doors, there's an
enemy. And we've got to circle the
wagon. You know what I mean? like and it
does it's a very rhetorically
emotionally powerful narrative that's
just like yes we and leaders know this
and so they they glue people together
you know by this deep opposition
and so we we kind of rally around and we
say yes yes yes the problem is them you
know and then of course what do we do we
then use the weapons of the world guns
bombs media propaganda smear campaigns
and so on and so forth to attack,
eliminate, or at least neutralize them.
And if we win, you know, there's peace
for a little while
until we find another problem, you know,
at which point, of course, the cycle
repeats. There's a problem and the
problem is them. There's a problem and
the problem is them. Sometimes, of
course, it gets reversed. This, not even
sometimes, all the time. And this is
something again in our church, we feel
very acutely, you know, where then
someone else says this to us, right?
there is a problem and the problem is
you you know in this like uhuh yeah
right this is just the dysfunctional way
of the world it's kind of the game
everyone's playing to sort of take it
out of the societal big picture level
and kind of you know zoom in a little
bit um at the individual level we might
say that um kind of the the worldly
mindset by that I I don't mean um not
thinking like sinner or something but
just the the kind of the way of the
world to use Paul's language you know
just the the normal mindset said is
basically to say, you know, I'm feeling
emotionally disregulated right now
because of you. You know, like that's
the that's the the narrative. Um, it's
your fault I'm this way. Only you can
fix me by changing. I demand that you
change so that I can change. I heard the
uh the kind of spiritual teacher David
Dan Fischer, he said, uh, all marital
arguments, I think this is a little
reductive, but I get what he's getting
at. He says, "All marital arguments
usually boil down to this. I'm
emotionally dregulated, so you change."
No, I'm emotionally dregulated, so you
change. No, I'm emotionally dregulated,
so you change. Right? By emotionally
disregulated, I just mean upset, you
know, feeling some kind of fear, shame,
anger, you know, just feeling off,
right? And uh this is just the way of
the world, right? And even I see this
like this crazy. I have three kiddos and
uh I experienced this with them where
I'm like so tempted even though it's
completely absurd. I'm like 40 years old
looking down, you know, at my like
14year-old or 10-year-old, you know, but
I'm very tempted to do this. Like, no,
I'm the reason I'm yelling right now is
because you are, you know, and of
course, it's it looks from the outside
looking in, it looks completely stupid.
You know what I mean? But for me, I'm
like, no, this is real. You know, uh,
this is the way of the world. It can be
partner to partner, parents to children,
children to parents, community to
community, country to country, right?
It's just this narrative playing out in
at different levels. I don't feel
emotionally well right now and it's your
fault. But Paul says there's another
way. It's just, you know, it's the way
no one likes. And uh this is why I
suspect even in churches in ways the uh
the way of Jesus, the spiritual path
always remain kind of marginal, you
know, a narrow path as Christ says that
few find. And I don't think he means
only, you know, only the few will go to
heaven or something. I think it means
more like uh not many of us will mature
into all we could because
this p this what we're getting at is so
difficult for us to swallow. You know,
just it's it's extremely challenging
because while the worldly person says,
"I'm emotionally disregulated because of
you." The kind of spiritual minded or or
spiritually mature person says, "No, no,
actually my emotions are my own. I'm
emotionally disregulated right now
because of me." Right? It's my own
devilish thoughts, insecurities, looping
storylines that are tripping me up over
and over and over again.
And yes, of course, people have have
done things are doing things that like
push the buttons, you know what I mean?
Like, oh my god, like no doubt.
However, if I'm waiting around for them
to change
so that I can feel better,
I'm going to be waiting a long, long
time.
In essence, I've got to begin taking
radical responsibility for my own
thoughts, feelings, reactions.
Verse five, we demolish arguments and
every pretension that sets itself up
against the knowledge of God. And we
take captive every thought
to make it obedient to Christ. Few
phrases I want to zero in on there.
Pretention and then that taking every
thought captive. We'll start with the
word pretention. It's kind of a strange
one. What does that mean? Pretention is
like masking. It's like dishonesty.
In essence, it's sort of being clever
like it's thinking thinking to yourself,
I know the truth and what I could say,
but I'm not going to say the truth
because I might lose. So, I'm going to
say the thing that will allow me to win,
you know, and if you look at the broader
context of 2 Corinthians 10, there's
this kind of power struggle going on in
the church with Paul, right? There's
basically some other teachers who have
come into the church and they're
attacking Paul and they're saying like,
"He's not that impressive. He's like,
sure, his letters are real good, but
they literally said this, but when he's
in person, he's not an impressive
speaker." You know, that's what they
said about Paul. It's just kind of funny
to think of Paul being like awesome
writer. He's in the Bible. Like
twothirds of the New Testament is Paul,
but in person he's like, "Hello,
everyone. So glad to be here." You know,
it's just like, "What the Paul? This is
You're supposed to be freaking awesome."
You know? So, they're kind of poking.
And so, there's this kind of egoic
battle going on right now. What are they
doing? They're fighting with the weapons
of the world, which is nasty when it
gets into the church. And now we're
doing it. you know,
these personal attacks, this slander,
this pretension, the lies and so on. And
so Paul's saying, "No, no, we must put
every thought, every argument, every
pretension, every story line, every
looping tape that runs through my head,
rentree, all of it must be noticed
and and kind of put through the the
ringer, the the filter of the truth."
How do you do that? You might ask
yourself questions like this.
Is this true
about a thought? That's actually a very
powerful question. It might seem
extremely underrated like what? But when
you have a thought, just ask,
is that true?
And it's shocking the degree to which,
you know, you're running with the whole
story and the whole thing. And then
you're like, is that true? Am I even
sure that it's true? You know, is that
who Christ says I am? Is this how Christ
has called me to act? Is this who I want
to become? Right? I think this is what
taking every thought captive can begin
to look like in our lives. It's what the
Christian preacher Joyce Meyer, I love
old Joyce,
she famously call Yeah, some of y'all
know. I'm so glad some of y'all remember
her, not everyone. Um, for those who
don't know Joyce Meer, she was like one
of the very early like female preachers
that was like on television back when,
well, I guess it's still kind of a big
thing, which is ridiculous, but back,
you know, before many churches were like
open to such things. And so, um, anyway,
so I like old Joyce in a lot of ways,
but she famously, um, wrote this book
called the the battlefield of the mind.
And, uh, I haven't read it, but I just
took the title and I thought, oh, I
think I know where you're going, so
maybe I'm totally misrepresenting Joyce
Mer. I don't know. But um it's so bad.
Um
but basically like in essence when I
think of that phrase I think of kind of
every day we're on this battlefield. And
if you come back to this weapons of the
world, you know what I mean? I think in
essence we get confused about which
battle we're fighting, right? We got
millions of Christians who think we're
in a culture war. you know, like we're
fighting the godless left, you know, the
wacky right or, you know, whatever.
We're fighting people from that religion
or more personally, you know, or my ex
or mother or father.
But Paul is saying that's a kind of
trick of the mind. it ends up
distracting us from the true battlefield
which is first and foremost right here
in my own mind in my own heart right the
way my um my professor put it for me he
said we often think we're bumping into
others
but actually most the time again not
always most of the time we're bumping
into ourselves it's our own feelings our
own reactions our own emotional upset
right
now does this I mean, okay, so there's
no room really for like political or
social action, you know. Does this mean
there's no societal ills to address? Am
I saying all this, you know, all the
real stuff's at the level of like the
individual, the the battlefield of a
person's mind? Um,
no. Like yes and no. Like no in the
sense that I do think there's not just
room, but it's essential like political
social kind of action. Um, I think
that's that's good and beautiful and
true. Yes, though in the sense that as
uh Father Richard Roar says, what is not
transformed is transmitted.
And so in essence, if we're going to do
that kind of work out there in the
world, you know, I mean, to write the
structures and to to help bring justice
and truth, you know, to others, uh
that's beautiful. However, if we're
going to do that, we must strive twice
as hard
to
ensure that we're taking every thought
captive and that as followers of Jesus
and honestly as sort of a largely kind
of on the margins church community where
it would be very easy for us to get
extremely embittered and I mean just
pissed at everyone, you know. Uh that
means like it's not fair. It sucks. But
that's going to be the the call and the
journey for us is to do that kind of
heart work.
So that well because otherwise we set
out on a holy war, you know, and we end
up transmitting
the very things we set out to transform.
As Jesus said, until you remove the log
from your own eye, how can you see
clearly to help another? Right? In
essence, the the person still seeing red
is just not in a place to bring healing
to someone else. You know what I mean?
They can't they can't discern the right
language and and emotional tone to even
connect with them. Uh I've experienced
this personally, not so much in like the
kind of, you know, political activist
sphere or whatever, but um more in the
leadership social sphere. I uh to kind
of just be vulnerable. I didn't realize
the degree to which starting the table
um would push all my buttons like like
in essence I I I don't know I think I
was others focus in that kind of
Christian sense which you think is all
good you know like I just we're going to
be here for others we're going to help
them it's going to be great and then you
kind of find yourself getting triggered
and pushed and your insecurities getting
exposed and uh and then it's like hard
you know and you find yourself like oh
no and uh just to give kind of a
practical so I don't keep this too high
level. You're like what exactly are you
talking about? Um just one example of
this would be in my mind I thought of
all of the beautiful wonderful folks the
new folks we would connect with at the
table. I never really emotionally
prepared for all of the people who would
leave
like that. I was like not I and in my
brain it's kind of like okay it'll be
great like let's launch out and then
over time you know not not envisioned
being a mega church any you know but
there's going to f some folks would join
and then a month goes by and some more
folks will join and go and then more f
and then we'll slowly grow and it'll be
beautiful. I wasn't counting for was
like well yes well two folks will join
and one will leave you know it's like oh
no and and it's hard emotionally like
sometimes because they move away or you
know um but sometimes like we we connect
with a lot of folks who are
deconstructing and just aren't sure
about Christian faith and like I don't
know about all this and this is kind of
like their last stop on the way out of
the church like forever you know it's
sort of the last ditch effort and so
some folks end up connecting and staying
and like finding healing and light and
some folks you know honestly are kind of
like yeah I can't do this you
And
that could that could it started it
could push my button my insecurity
button you know and like hey we're going
to leave
and then the battlefield of the mind
starts getting pushed you know of like
god am I not am I not good enough am I
what I what do we do wrong you know like
all the well and then it can get twisted
Like can you see where all of a sudden
if you're not doing this inner work like
I think this is where we we talked about
toxic spirituality and even like toxic
pastors and make all the in you know
social media rounds like as a pastor I
totally get like how they get there
because you start getting all insecure
and all afraid
and you got to start manipulating people
to keep them maybe start preaching on
hell a little bit more. You know what I
mean? Like all of a sudden, before you
know it, you start off to again do this
beautiful thing in the world. I'm going
to bring the love of Christ.
And before you know it, you're in a bad
bad place.
And
and so for me, what it looks like is
learning when folks
come and then go, learning to say, you
know what? They are free. They are free.
God's got them. God's got me. It's okay.
Right? Can you see where that it opens
up this beautiful space where my
feelings are my own? It's not like,
well, how dare you make me feel this
way? You what? No. No. People are free
to come to go to be led by the spirit.
And that's that's the the work at least
for me. And of course, you can kind of
map it onto your own life. You know how
that looks. the places where you get
triggered and pushed and and and all
that and uh
and it's it's a I think a process of
Christ inviting us to learn right I'm
learning now I have not learned the past
tense I'm I'm learning uh learning to
take that responsibility to say goodbye
to folks and even to bless and they're
going the aesthetic one of the great
Christian spiritual masters of the
seventh century he said it is beyond our
power to prevent obsessive thoughts from
troubling and disturbing the soul. But
it is within our power to forbid such
imaginings to linger within and to
forbid such obsessions to control us.
Right? In other words, none of us can
literally like you know the battlefield
of the mind means stop those thoughts
just stop. You know good luck that's
it's not that. But what we can do is
notice notice coming back to those
questions. Is it true? Is that true?
what am I feeling right now? Am I
projecting onto them or is this just me?
You know, it's that that process. So,
how can we do this? To kind of close
out, I'll give you some uh kind of
practical handles on like maybe what it
can look like to actually start taking
your thoughts captive and such. So,
number one, record your thoughts or
feelings in a journal.
It's like the cheapest therapy you'll
ever get, a journal. When you name a
thought or a feeling, you start to gain
some critical distance from it. you
know, it's like you're getting out of
your system, so to speak. Um, also, as
you journal, take take some ownership
for those feelings, right? Instead of
using the whole journaling time to like,
can you believe how they made me feel,
you know, but it's naming like, oh, this
is what's going on in me. This is what
I'm feeling right now. Uh, second, some
deep breathing. Everyone take a deep
breath in,
out through the mouth.
That's good. That's right. That's that
calming that nervous system, you know.
Um this is the breath is a very powerful
way to calm ourselves. And so whenever
you find yourself getting in that
emotionally upregulated place it's very
powerful. Just take some time and do
some deep breathing. Um third the Jesus
prayer or another uh short repeated
prayer. Some people call this a breath
prayer. A prayer you can like say in one
breath. U so the the Christian spiritual
master Theophen the recluse he explains
it nicely. He says when we pray, we must
stand in our mind before God and think
of him alone. And yet various thoughts
keep jostling in the mind and draw it
away from God in order to teach the mind
to rest on one thing. The Holy Father
has used short prayers and acquired the
habit of reciting them unceasingly.
So this isn't so much necessarily just
about a prayer time like my morning
prayers. This is about like in your life
as you drive uh do the dishes you know
just whenever you're doing something
where you can actually kind of say a
quick prayer and you just repeat this
prayer. He says the unceasing repetition
of a short prayer kept the mind on the
thought of God and dispersed all
irrelevant thoughts. They adopted
various short prayers but it is the
Jesus prayer which has become
particularly established amongst us and
is most generally employed. And it goes
Lord Jesus Christ son of God have mercy
upon me a sinner. Uh this can be
shortened by the way just to Lord Jesus
Christ uh have mercy or even just Lord
Jesus my favorite Lord Jesus mercy just
real short just Lord Jesus mercy.
So my challenge to you this week is to
begin uh as best you can start to take
some ownership for those thoughts, those
feelings. Um not in some weird
personally blamy, judgmental way, but in
a kind of empowering way of hey I want
to grow
and this is my path to the peace of
Christ. In the name of the father, the
son and the holy spirit. Amen.
So
on the night that Jesus was betrayed, he
had one final meal with his disciples.
And at that meal, he held a loaf of
bread and he broke it. And he said,
"Take it. Eat. This is my body. It's
broken for you." Then he held up a cup
of wine. He said, "Take this. Drink.
This is my blood. It's shed for you.
Whenever you eat this bread, whenever
you drink this cup, remember me." And so
as we come forward to partake of the
Lord's supper, that's uh what we're
participating in. It's a a reconnection
uh with Christ and the connection uh
with one another as we become his uh
body. So uh the way we'll kind of
participate tonight and go about this,
we'll just start on the front row and
we'll just form one line here in the
middle and we'll just kind of go row by
row so when one one row is done, the
next one can jump in line. Um, you
should know that the red is wine, the
white is grape juice. Uh, also we
practice what's called an open table.
Meaning, if you're here tonight and
you'd like to participate, then you're
free to do that regardless of your
exact, you know, theology or background
or whatever. Um, you're you're free to
participate in this time. Uh, and then
finally, you can just partake whenever
you'd like. Some folks like to come and
kneel and partake there on the sides.
Some take immediately. You can or you
can return to your seat. However you
want to do it, no one will lead you
through the exact moment of partaking
the elements. So this is the table not
of the church
but of the Lord and it's made ready for
those who love him and for those who
want to love him more. So come you who
have much faith and you who have little.
You who have been here often and you who
have not been here long. You who have
tried to follow and you who feel like
you failed. Come. Come because it's the
Lord Jesus himself who invites you and
it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet him here. Come to
the table.
[Music]
As we close out tonight, we're going to
sing a song called Someday Soon. And I
just invite you guys to sit and soak it
in. Um being a human is hard work and
sometimes we just need to remember um
that that work is not for nothing and um
like we were talking about earlier. Um
there's enough mercy for tomorrow and
God will meet us there in it. Joy comes
in the morning.
There is a shadow in the hallway
trying to frighten you.
Don't let the darkness
surround you.
You can make it through.
Don't you give up
on the kingom.
Think it's crashing in.
No, it ain't worth
all the wor
this to let you in.
Someday
soon these worries roll on.
someday
soon
enough.
Sometimes the weight
of decisions
will try to bury you.
Don't let the shame
tell you something
that you know ain't true.
>> Just cuz you feel
like a stranger
that don't mean you are
God. I could use
a reminder
what forgiveness is for.
Some days
[Music]
worries roll.
love
[Music]
soon
enough.
[Music]
Someday
soon these worries roll on.
some days soon
enough.
[Music]
>> Sometimes the cold
wind blows,
sometimes the wolves
rush in.
Don't think the battle's
over just cuz they say
amen.
[Music]
>> Sometimes the cold
wind blows.
Sometimes the world
rushing.
Don't think the battle's
over
just cuz they say amen.
[Music]
Someday
soon these worries roll on.
[Music]
Some days
you
need
[Music]
some
worries wrong.
[Music]
Someday
soon
enough,
>> someday
[Music]
soon
No.
[Music]
Thanks everyone for joining us e this
evening. Thanks worship band. That was
awesome. I really enjoyed it today. Um
if you're new here um we would love for
you to fill out a card. It's on the
table to my left on your way out. Um or
you can also scan this lovely QR code
that's up behind me. There's going to be
lots of information there and we just
like to know that you are here. Um we
can all use some more relational support
here at the table. The way that we do
that is through our meetups. If you're
not part of a meetup yet, you can scan
this QR code again and find one that's
uh convenient for your area.
Generosity is a key aspect of a life of
adoration and worship. If the table is
your church home, we would invite you to
scan the QR code and give financially or
you can visit the tabletx.org.
[Music]
All right, let me send you out into your
week with a blessing. You can hold out
your hands in a posture to receive or
you can just open your heart to these
words.
You are a child of God.
This is true on your best day and it's
true on your worst.
So as you go into your week with yet to
be determined highs and lows and
everything in between, go filled with
the assurance that you are loved,
you are worthy, and you are accepted
exactly as you are. And go filled with
God's Holy Spirit and the desire to
extend these same gifts of grace and
unconditional love to everyone you come
into contact with.
Thank you.
>> Someday
soon these worries roll on.
Someday
soon
enough
[Music]
someday
soon these worries roll on
soon
enough.
[Music]
>> Someday
soon
enough.
[Music]